whale sharks are wonderfully beautiful
animals the biggest fish in the ocean
growing to 20 or 30 feet in length and
they're intimidating
we went all the way across the Raja
Ampat area to gender Wasi Bay to shoot a
sequence of whale sharks it's the only
place in the world where we can film
this many wal sharks at one time the
first view it's awe-inspiring I mean it
literally leaves you speechless
I'm literally laughing out loud this is
one of the most remarkable experiences
I've ever had in my life
and everything about you is going oh my
god you're an overload because these
beautiful creatures are coming right by
you and there's still that fear factor
when Joey our main character saw the
size of those whale sharks he was
nothing I'm not gonna do that our little
star Joey who was 13 years old was the
sweetest most wonderful boy
that you would ever want to meet
his grandfather was bit by a shark and
lost part of his arm so he had this as a
memory that anything with the name shark
in it is not a friendly thing
we put on the McGann just to sort of
look at the well shot and he watched for
about 20 minutes before he felt Cup now
it
within the first 5 10 minutes of him
being in the water he was as happy as
can be
he was completely a fish as they were
they can care less if you're in the
water or not they wanted the fish as
soon as he got in and started swimming
around him he experienced the same kind
of joint and he was laughing
there's a couple shots we got where he
was actually feeding him
whale sharks feed by opening their
mouths expelling the water through their
gills and then keeping the fish their
mouths are Otherworld about three feet
wide two feet in in height and they just
open them and suck this water
we must have shot 14 rolls of film IMAX
it's a really really unique incredible
opportunity you know we are all just
having a blast
you know just turned out to be better
than we ever expected
when we asked Joey what was his favorite
thing he said absolutely the whale shark
you